ما كان بالامس تخمينات صار اليوم حقيقه
دونالد ترامب يواجه بيتها من جنائيه في
سابقه تاريخيه في غمره الحمله الانتخابيه
للحصول على ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري الرئيس
الامريكي السابق الذي سبق لاعلن انه
سيواجه الاعتقال على موعد مع السلطات
القضائيه في ولايه نيويورك ما تزال تفاصيل
القضيه تحت غطاء السريه لكن وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه تتحدث عن قضيه دفع مبالغ ماليه
لاسكات ممثله اباحيه كانت على علاقه
بالترام في مخالفه لقانون تمويل الحملات
الانتخابيه وقانونيه سجلات الضرائب توجيه
التهم على اهميته قد لا يؤثر في حضور
ترامب الانتخابيه بل يقول محامي الرئيس
السابق ان الاعتقال قد يقنع فئه من
الامريكيين ان الدوله العميقه تمنعن في
اضطهاده وقانونيا لا تمنع النصوص المعتمده
في الولايات المتحده المساجين من الترشح
بل واداره البلاد من الزنزانه في حال فوزه
في الانتخابات ويواجه ترامب الطامح الى
البيت الابيض في خريف العام المقبل رئيسا
للولايات المتحده جمله من التحقيقات منها
ما هو مدني ومنها ما هو جنائي واخرى تتعلق
بالامن القومي ابرز القضايا المدنيه ما
تحقق فيه ولايه نيويورك في شبهه التقليل
ممتلكاته وتضخيم نفقاته لاسباب تتعلق
بالتهرب الضريبي والقيام بالعكس لاقتراض
الاموال من البنوك اما السلطات التحقيق في
ولايه جورجيا فتنظر في مزاعم محاوله ترامب
وحلفائه التدخل في نتائج انتخابات سنه
2020 وفيدراليا يحقق مكتب التحقيقات في
اداره ترامب للوثائق السريه التي كانت في
عهدته اثناء ممارسه مهامه وسبق لفريق من
المكتب ان اغار على مقر اقامته في مارلاجو
فلوريدا حيث استعاد عشرات الوثائق عدد
منها على اعلى درجات السريه وبعضها يحتوي
اسرار نوويه وكل هذه التحقيقات مستمره خلف
الستار ولم يتكشك من تفاصيلها سوى القليل
[موسيقى]